there was a scripted moment when the
character was supposed to break down and
when we got to it we felt forced and
Ridley and I kind of looked at each
other and were like this doesn't feel
right does it I'm good
I'm anxious to get up to
thanks for coming back for me we'd
shocked stuff with the other actors
months earlier but they'd all gone home
and Ridley and I had made all those
scenes but just together where it was
just me on camera and so suddenly I
heard in my helmet as the you know as
the gimbal starts to shudder suddenly I
heard the voices of all of these actors
who were my buddies you know and and
it's and it dawned on me you know
thinking through the kind of the filter
of this character like he hadn't heard a
voice
in a year and that these people had made
this sacrifice to come back for him
Pilate
go
it was so humbling it just totally
happened and it wasn't planned that's
just great directing that's Ridley just
just kind of put a move on me I didn't
see it coming